hey hey what's up my fellow geeks this
is zacky from geek culture and uh this
is gonna be a different video this is
gonna be a reaction video
um
for horror games and trailers and
everything
that's scary and
i i hate
horror games i love them i just oh man
this is
yeah i don't even know why i'm putting
myself in this situation but uh
you know youtube content right yeah
so today we're gonna watch the show it's
our official release trailer and it's
supposed to be some lovecraftian horror
um i don't know
game and it has monsters and
it's it's just gonna be scary so
yeah let's just watch it
dude the shore
[Music]
this island feels like it's maintained
untouched by time
the wind and the waves pause for a
minute to rest
the calm before the storm so this is uh
we're gonna be in abandoned island or
something
[Music]
looks great though
feels like a semi-open world with some
puzzles in it
[Applause]
i'm gonna find all these dials
marks and stuff
yo that's
that's crazy man
that's wild man
oh he's just kind of like opened
oh man
that's wild
so february 19th 2021 so
yeah
well that's
that was a lot of things wasn't it so
with that being said the great news is
we do have the demo of the game and you
yourself can play it
uh just go to itch.io
and search the show and you should be
able to find the game
uh to play uh the demo and
you know this
from what i've heard
this uh
the guy who developed the game he's
pretty much a one-man show so this is
all done by one person
and you know if you wanna give your
support we'll put the link down in the
description below
of course you can also add it to your
steam wishlist which will be coming out
on february 19th
of this year 2021 so
yeah let's head to the game and before
we continue support our channel by
giving us a like share and subscribing
alright so we got the show demo loaded
up
and let's just go straight to the game
okay whoa
bye dear
early that is the fighter
right now i only get to play it on 2k
settings but man on the 60fps lock
and uh for those of you who are
uh who do have
high refresh rate monitors you can
actually play it up to 144 hertz
oh it's a little birdie
it's a led bulb that's a
strange
strange little bird huh we got the
seashore
we got some lighthouse over there shall
we go over there
i think we should get over there
some strange things so you gotta go
you got a pressure
oh what a man needs to keep moving
before he loses his sanity and his will
walking along the shore reminded me of
the walks i used to have with my wife
open the inventory to learn more about
items required
from when i will walk through the valley
of
death
i will fear no evil
and walk
through the dark
eyes
that's cool
you can press i
yo
oh okay yeah i got confused real quick
so this is the locket
uh my wife gave this pendant to ellie
before she left us
glad to have found this it's very
important to her
i refuse to believe my daughter was
swallowed by the vicious sea i'm sure
she was
washed up on the shore somewhere around
here
i will find her and give this back i
guess we're just going to walk around
the shore and we
can eat some eggs is this a survival
game right you got to survive we got to
eat some eggs
[Applause]
okay so so it's a semi-open world you
can't really go over the rocks but man
the textures dude look at them
yeah
wow
got seashells you got conks
man i wish could run though
oh wow
they speak of a fisherman who was lost
in a stranded sea
he never came back
now i know where he lies
well misfortunes could have drove him
here it's more more washed up
boats
this
offered my right arm and spoke the
correct words in his absence only pain
accompanies me towards my demise
i was forced to leave the lighthouse
there's something wrong with all of us
only the slumbering god can save us now
what
is he talking about
that's it
so i gotta go a long ways again oh
i didn't see that
yo
okay
um
okay i was speaking in
that language ancient language i believe
kakula relay
seems like we've got
i wonder uh one can only wonder huh
let's go in
the play
and the party here
it's got like a sawmill and stuff
dude
this guy's equipped
ah
i see you're mad of culture
paint
dude
so what is the key here we've got the
key
and
what about us
all this
drink it is
what the hell is this
this artifact we found this actually
looks ancient
our captain says we should take it back
with us
could make us rich
david of
david
on the other hand
correction
stick
believe is that a fault stench of evil
girls within it what an utter rubbish
from the moment we wrecked here he
hasn't stopped talking about bad luck
and outer world omens i heard him
talking to himself about throwing it
back to the sea
i'm almost certain he's mad he's
obsessed
these disgusting leeches he found
can't stop talking about how these worms
have at least nine stomachs
and more than 30 brains and at least 18
sorry what
more than 30 brains and at least
18 testicles yeah talks about that
quality matters rather than quantity
we couldn't stop making jokes about it
last night
and after that
he took it personally
as we were walking we moved to the third
floor of the lighthouse to continue his
little experiment okay so we kind of got
a drawings of the monster
un
normal body shape no symmetrical shape
that could define a logical form
unsymmetrical bowels of its body
disputed and injured and quite forgotten
it's been 27 days since we are here and
we came across something that
our minds cannot comprehend
how could such things exist how does god
justify this
how can he allow such monsters to roam
upon his creation
my mind is terrorized a million times
each time i try to visualize this beast
my hands are shaking as i draw each line
as if it was a plague of the mind
i decided to give it a name the monster
of a thousand mouths
though it may seem strange but i heard a
voice
more like a whisper shivering down my
spine through my ears
[Music]
oh man why do
okay so we got some kind of
humanoid
thing going on no eyelids a short blue
tongue
shock eyes body structure seems to be
very strong
i tried to speak to them but in return
they hissed and growl and made all kinds
of weird noises no trace of language
i've never seen such creatures before
something is wrong
you're like the god have forsaken this
place at its creations
the fish like people are no humans at
all they are hostile they seem to be
very aggressive
there's no trace of civilized behavior
on them
yet they seem to understand our
movements as if they have been humans
before the fish-like deformities on them
are present
they have tried several times to ambush
us
the only solution for us is to stay near
the lighthouse
i will study more these are
abominations of the deep
cure
kill
so many okay so
so i guess
see the people were shipwrecked here and
you know they've
they've um kind of like landed
themselves into this island as well and
then you know
bush could use
we're on the third floor lighthouse we
were from the yonder over there
it looks like there's a dead ass shark
over there i feel like checking that out
you know yeah establish yourself in the
perimeter of the area as they say
and if we zoom in it looks like a very
solid looking boat
so could that be our quick getaway
oh okay we gotta find our daughter right
gosh okay
maybe she was sacrificed
yes
let's carry on to the top of the
lighthouse now
[Music]
oh good
oh wow okay
i fixed it we finished the game
i fixed the lighthouse ladies and
gentlemen that's all we needed to do
quas is complete okay goodbye no scary
stuff that's a great run thank you guys
uh
well i guess this is the demo so you
just gotta follow the lights right
hmm
this game seems promising already
actually
something here
nothing here
[Music]
oh
oh [__]
did you guys see that
[Music]
ah man just
just as soon as the ominous music came
in
aren't you
proceeding
there's something i would like to show
you
yo
what is my knees or something get out of
my head
dude
um
uh it's okay man i'm just gonna go back
and you know
um
y'all y'all like um
i'm just gonna just hang in the shot and
just start to death because that's
nah man
[Music]
yo dude
skadoosh
[Music]
when there's something that's so ominous
sounding right
it's like he's basically telling you
like dude um
take the dial
trust me
and like you can get off this island
right
i was like yeah we all know the plot to
this
bad
it's not gonna work
it doesn't move
so i can't take this on another thing
and we're right at the tower
same
island trying to get my bearings but
i have no idea where i am right now so
we got one
two three four
four monoliths
i'm guessing none of these will move
each of their own designs
so this looks like the one in this
second
oh something
okay
oh 10 over 10 man the water looks
fantastic by the way
i don't know is there some correlation
to all this i don't know
it's a dread dude can we run
already right
and
nothing
not yet
this is huge though
head man
that's gonna hurt
uh
sorry okay so now we're back to the
first one everything else is spinning
[Music]
aha
yes
[__]
and grasp time in your conscious mind
oh my god it's moving dude yo that's
creepy dude
no
[Music]
i don't understand this game
i don't know
i don't know anymore oh
[Music]
so much death
oh there's not even like fresh
characters just like
the ghoulish ones
i didn't even know
i'm so scared they're gonna come out
how do you
get up
[Music]
okay
dude
[Music]
so much anxiety dude
okay we can see the distance that the
monolith is moving so
i guess that's a good thing
do we have to go
forward here or
[Music]
okay we can't well i wasted time okay
that's pretty cool
it's it's really kind of like a
semi-open wool so everything's moving
you know you don't
it don't cut to a different scene
and i like that a lot so
that being said is there something we
can unlock now we have a key
i'm not sure we can do the key
[Music]
oh
wait
ski to a basement
the key works
oh [__]
oh dude
no
huh
and they managed to let him die in here
okay
okay so he has the dial we have one dial
[Music]
and uh
what's this handprint here
their handprints
why what happened to this dude
and his writing cryptic
so this was the guy was probably totally
mad
i was doing a lot of research
and stuff just like super obsessed with
this place
okay so i'm glad there wasn't any
jumpiness yeah it was that was whack
[Music]
does it work
yes
oh i can run
this place feels like it was always a
part of me
as if it has taken a hold of me and will
not go i don't even know what i'm
running or not
another foot in the sand but this time
sink deeper beneath the shore
so i still can run
this is bad
[Music]
you don't have you don't dare to walk
the shores
when the night comes something in the
dark seems to follow us in great speed
we hid inside the small cave we got to
stay there for the rest of the night
begin to fear that we are no longer safe
in this island we have to leave we have
to leave but seems everything works
against us
its long tentacle legs seem to be very
strong
a boulder before it shuttered into
pieces
with a single strike
my other half mind tells me i should
stay behind and study them and the other
half tells me i should leave i should
leave now
john one of the crew members found a
camera if we get it to work we should
try taking pictures
[Music]
working upon my daughter's toy gave me
some sort of happiness dead but that is
pop and i can't take my mind off the
idea she's been taken by one of those
creatures
[Music]
what creatures
there's things nah
harmless
they don't do nothing
[Music]
yo
okay
solitude and peace is what a soul seeks
after being free
that they die in vain
[Music]
it appears they were murdered
what a horrible way to find solitude
what happened you dude
[Music]
dude just taking a weefy
and
you got murdered by sea people
oh man
dude that's just
that's just sad
feel like surprise
[Music]
and if they were taking a wee fee why is
the camera facing the other way should
was it here i got confused
you're just standing there one day
yeah
dude
[Music]
excuse me sir there's a conte issue
all right ah either way so this boat
the orca
something there too
oh what the f was that is that a bb
what
[Music]
dude that was creepy af dude
cannot believe my eyes this picture
shows a monstrous creature flinging his
tentacles around
photographic is to have been taken
closer to the show too
sea is vast and the depths are full of
dangerous specimens but this monster is
too much
they know what lies at the bottom of the
sea but this fiend is close to the shore
it's a nightmare do you sing
okay
dude what was that dude was that my
daughter
ellie
ellie where are you
it's me
your dad
it's not a lot like brain
right now
um
oh my
oh
[__]
[Music]
i'll do anything
no anything to see her face again
dude
[Music]
e
got my ex back
nice
no sir
you shaking still glitching
you're my rembra
[Music]
diving suit
okay
all right
what can i swim now
oh
you will find
your destiny
[Music]
we are just i'm just hearing stuff man
this is crazy
where do i go
[Music]
to lose stature again
oh
[Music]
what's going on
we just finished the game
[Music]
what's what
and this is what i call running
[Music]
open
oh okay
nice
oh sh oh [__]
oh [__]
kill it
beam
away
the hell dude
[Music]
what
we fit
so what the the beam just stops them
okay fine and we'll just do that
yo that's that's hella cool though
oh go away
ah
ah you can't get me foul beast
go away
[Music]
ah
so i got a it's like a maze
um
oh shoots
come on man
dude
oh man
you just got a bladder
and then you gotta move quick
okay
i'm just gonna beam you straight up bro
dude how am i supposed to know
oh go away dude
why
are you
dude
oh what was that
oh my gosh
oh run run run run run run run
what
what the hell
oh
oh okay
okay
you stand before him
slobbering god
i have sealed him from within
break him free
no i think it's okay we'll just let him
sleep huh i mean
[Music]
it's been a while i know but uh
you know um
yeah i'm your master now
what i didn't do anything i just set you
free man dude
um
okay oh [__]
why
hello
hello friend
oh wasn't so bad
all right
well done dudes
very interesting
thank you everyone i hope you enjoyed
the demo due to coronal virus lockdown
and narrations will record using a cell
phone i want to thank everyone who
helped me with their positive energy
from social media that made this
come true and kept me going what your
son then was just tip of the iceberg and
there's more to come
all the characters in the game were
created based on real life people that
are close to me so
can we set a story and play again from
the beginning
if you wanted to
please send us feedback and report any
bugs you found
oh okay that was a very interesting
um game actually
wow
and we are less than a month
shy from this game so
yeah let us know in the comments if you
want us to play the full game i hope you
enjoyed this commentary of
the show demo gameplay
as well as our reaction to the trailer
um this has been fun
and interesting
well we hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you do don't forget to like share
and subscribe and smash that
notification bell icon so you can see
more
game reactions gameplays commentaries
and uh yeah do let us know in the
comments below what would you like me
zack
uh to play what's the next scary game
that i should be playing cause
i really don't want to do this but
content
so
tune in next time folks
[Music]